over the past few months the price of
gold has been going
haywire you can see it on this chart as
the coronavirus pandemic took hold in
march
the price crashed alongside stocks and
then
quickly regained then a frenzy of
investment drove up the price to
all-time highs
on august 4th it shot past two thousand
dollars a troy
ounce for the first time ever before
another week of big swings
this volatility is drawing both main
street and wall street investors seeking
fast gains
and leading some analysts to call it a
modern day gold rush
but these big moves call into question
gold's reputation
as a safe haven asset prices can move at
a moment's notice without fundamental
reason
more volatility means more risk and that
means gold isn't the haven necessarily
that some people think it is
to understand why the price of gold is
so volatile
first you need to understand how gold
trading works
like other precious metals the price of
gold is tied to physical assets
the physical gold market involves mining
refining
travel and sale gold mining happens on
every continent
except antarctica and the top producing
countries are
china russia and australia
this work adds up to about 2 500 to 3
000 metric tons of gold
each year this metal is then smelted and
refined before being turned into bars
coins and other products like jewelry
the gold is then shipped around the
world
often stashed in the cargo of commercial
aircrafts
much of it is sent to london mostly
hidden beneath the streets of the city
the bank of england's vaults hold around
400 000
bars of gold worth over 260 billion
dollars
the physical trading of gold in london
is done behind closed doors and in
secret by a few banks
so these banks work with the london
bullion market association to set the
physical price of a troy ounce of gold
and that price determines how much gold
is worth everywhere
the gold stash in london is rivaled only
by the federal reserve bank of new york
which holds the world's largest hoard of
physical gold
in other places around the world gold is
a common investment as well
in a lot of cultures in asia people see
gold as something that's
having prestige and intrinsic value that
can be passed down
from generation to generation that can
be a big source of physical demand for
jewelry and bars and coins
individual investors want to buy in they
generally have a few options
they can purchase physical gold in
person from dealers or on websites like
ap max
they can bid on thousands of dollars
worth of gold through ebay
and they can buy exchange traded funds
that hold physical metal
the biggest of these is spdr gold shares
which is traded on the new york stock
exchange but this
is just the physical market gold is also
traded on a whole different market that
is tied to commodity futures
this takes us back to new york where
gold futures trade on the comex division
of the new york mercantile exchange
futures are contracts which lock the
price of a commodity that will
change hands at a specific future date
a standard futures contract is tied to a
hundred ounces of gold
worth over two hundred thousand dollars
depending on the market
the most actively traded month for gold
futures right now
is december because that's a month
people expect
the pandemics issues to maybe be
resolved by and it's a month around
november's presidential election a lot
of people are very nervous about the
outcome of that election and that it
might be delayed
so they're using these december gold
futures to give themselves options and
protect against market turmoil
but gold has slipped lately after a long
run-up
a reminder that momentum in this market
can change quickly
still this hasn't stopped gold bugs and
there are a few reasons why people
continue to pile money into the metal
right now
for a lot of investors it started in
march when mines refineries and airlines
shut down
across the world upending the system
usually used to move
gold across the atlantic and stabilize
prices
but when the pandemic hit investors
feared there wouldn't be a way to
physically move gold between the markets
this caused physical gold purchases to
soar
leading to a severe shortage that drove
up the price of futures
but there are other reasons too there
are a lot of people who are very bullish
on gold and think it's an alternative
currency
that provides a hedge against inflation
and is very attractive when interest
rates are low
many bulls are piling into the sector
because they think the federal reserve
and other
central banks are eroding the value of
paper money by pumping a ton of cash
into the global financial system to
support the economy
the increased activity is contributing
to momentum trading
driving a frenzy for gold similar to
stocks but if inflation doesn't
materialize
the momentum that gold is seeing could
unravel
analysts say the current trading
environment is extremely risky
people say all of the economic and
political instability could
last for a lot longer than we think at
the same time if the economic recovery
goes better than expected if there's a
coronavirus vaccine
more quickly than we think gold could
have some issues
this means that gold could face more
volatility moving forward
you